sur vaud ce qu'on vérifie si vous êtes
des bon papa etc enfin s'il n'était
review papa
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà regretter
d'avoir eu un enfant
pardon
j'ai regretté d'avoir eu un enfant non
vous avez déjà demander un test de
paternité parce que l'enfant avait l'air
un peu con
demander un test de paternité parce que
l'enfant avait l'air un peu vif
vous avez déjà fait un enfant pour faire
plaisir à la mer non non non non non
vous vous rappelez de toutes les mères
de vos enfants oui or la plupart oui
vous avez assisté à la naissance
dernièrement vaut bien sûr vous avez
filmé ah non ah ouais j'ai assisté
j'étais derrière elle moi je voulais
devant elle elle m'a dit non tu dis que
c'est mieux
vous avez déjà changer les couches de
vos enfants oui oui les biberons vous
les faites à elles allaitent mais jamais
je mettais pas très très bien au début
ouais un peu le bordel que les couches
non l'aller l'allaitement
est ce que vous avez déjà giflé un
enfant régulièrement martin le petit
martin
par exemple oui vous avez déjà oublié
votre enfant quelque part à part sur le
toit de ma voiture n'ont pas beaucoup
vous proposer de la drogue à vos enfants
pour être sûr qu'ils en prennent
je demande un temps mort dans cette
interview d'un joker je ne peux plus
aller il ya des blagues s'arrête
mais est-ce que vous avez déjà demandé à
votre enfant de rien dire à la mer à
propos de l'actrice dénudées qui étaient
là pour sa carrière en fait vous arriver
ça te dirait que
je vous ai déjà demandé à votre enfant
ne rien dire à sa mère à propos de ces
deux jeunes actrices dénudées qui
voulait juste des oui non oui tout à
fait non c'était un mais en plus il est
rompu en parler cette année vraiment pas
de gestionnaire
et oui dieu dans leur phase est
troisième ouais mais je serai toujours
pas lui avoir tâtonné d'euros
je n'aurais pas devenu magicien même pas
qui va être drôle banny
est ce que vous avez demandé de
renforcer
à propos de ces deux jeunes actrices
dénudées qui voulait juste des conseils
pour sa carrière
je voudrais utiliser votre enfant pour
draguer des filles dans les jardins
publics
non
je peux pas la main mois et toujours
avec la petite synthe
vous ai déjà fait travailler votre
enfant à la non-sanction moi ça pas de
faire un tapis de 2 ce matin je te jure
j'ai perdu un pognon pour les
ordinateurs et des pompes mais j'ai
regardé les télétubbies sans prendre de
drogue à la
wii et je me suis fait chier est-ce que
vous avez déjà fait oh qu'il est mignon
ouagadougou 12 au bout du goût doux oui
mais en regardant sa [ __ ]
il se dressa
si vous avez déjà promis à sa mère que
jamais au grand jamais vous
l'acquitterez ah ouais ouais ah non mais
ça c'est sûr c'est sûr elle est la femme
de ma vie ah oui
un texto un texto des jeux dit pour dire
que ces barres est
tombée est-ce que votre enfant vous a
déjà appelé monsieur tellement n'était
pas habitué à vous voir à la maison
[Rires]
je salue l'équipe des chrétiens
n'ont toujours pas déjà caresser les
cheveux de votre enfant en pensant à
l'économie d'impôt que ça vous fait
faire maurice déjà j'en viens pas
qu'elle ait des cheveux
franchement ça je me serais pas pris ça
de son père c'est vrai qu'elle n'a plus
de cheveux que vos gardes mais par excès
le film marche je vais vous laisser
pousser les cheveux c'est vrai je vais
me payer une perruque en or à
aller très bien
vous avez collet bébé à bord à l'arrière
de votre porsche cayenne alors j'ai
juste le bébé à bord ils
vous avez jamais regretté de pas avoir
pris un chien plutôt n'ont aucune ligne
ou
non mais non je
si je trouve de laval ont d'ailleurs
offert hier un moment et vous l'intégrer
ta jusqu'à samedi s'est dépêché samedi
j'irai réponse vannes demain vendredi je
fais mais j'ai la réponse tu viens on
rappelle les gens échangent tout genre
et on tourne laval est ce que vous avez
peur que vos enfants vous ressemble un
jour mon
nom mais apparemment les gens disent
qu'elle me ressemble je vais vite sans
les jolies
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
leader des tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu